I like the girl she killed more yeah
yeah I thought she was hotter really you
like Americana girl not a girl I'm not
into gallery
[Music]
what do you think would possess somebody
to want to kill
a person that looked just like them they
hate them doppelganger they want to be
the only one oh that's like jelly they
hate their twin the one self-hate they
don't want to be replaced they don't
want to be replaced uh the doppelganger
used the fact that they look like you to
have sex with your significance
it's getting hotter or they're trying to
identity theft for real interesting it's
by their twin it's sort of like that but
look at it this way there's a girl her
she's a German Iraqi girl 23 years old
that sounds hot cheesy she actually is
like very good looking so this is in
Germany very good looking or like okay
um
goes scouring the internet looking for a
person that looks like her to fake her
own death did you see it started no I
didn't yeah
did he get it sorry that's exactly right
whoa I killed it wait how does it help
you fake your own death
no yeah so what she did is her and her
boyfriend they wanted to run away
together okay the way that they figured
that out was to look for a girl that
looked just like her and then she kind
of uh would send all these offers to
different women who look like her online
to meet up and under the guise of like
it being a Cosmetics offer like we're
gonna give you something so they drive
her car over to this random girl that
just happens to look like her they put
her in the car and they stab her to the
point of being almost unrecognizable in
the face 50 times oh my God but make a
[__] DNA dude so stupid I bet you
should you know it's a very stupid crime
I know this because I watch House of
dragons and they did some they did this
move on House of dragons the DNA on
House of dragon no
somebody wanted to pretend that they
were dead what if we do this you stab
them right and then you stab a little
bit yourself DNA DNA and then oh yeah
sealed up sealed up don't forget the
jizz on soda so the ID inside throw it
up oh my God what do you think about
that this [__] is our side come inside
and she's German those are the two most
hardcore cultures that could be that's
true maybe that maybe that's what she's
Iraqi German plan so what they did was
they they stabbed her up and they put
her in the car and then they just like
bounced and they were hoping that upon
investigation people would come and go
oh it must be here because it looks like
it's a car
and then uh obviously only after a short
time you realize it's not her because it
looks like her and it's her car these
guys are the best they're they're like
thinking everyone's like Stone Age
investigation oh all she wanted to do
some dick yeah but isn't it crazy that
what if that was like she went through
multiple different girls and this is
just the one that bit how scary is that
to to see a message from her and you
didn't go oh my God you could have been
that girl you know what that means
because she's so dumb that means she's
[__] smoking
who did the stabbing though her
boyfriend her name is sharaban k oh you
think she did it childbon's okay name
sharaban's an okay baby yeah it's not
smoking oh she just lost points yeah
yeah because she sounds like Shadow band
you think the people that like maybe got
a message that looked like her but
didn't become the victim do you think
they have survivor's guilt no what is
that that's when you survive and you
feel guilty because because it should
have been you survivor's Guild is when
you survive and you feel guilty
survivor's Guild Guild all right so
here's um
her and the doppelganger which one do
you think is which oh whoa which one
she's the one on the left the one on the
right is hotter the one on the right
doesn't have a filter that's why the one
on the left got like yeah
I see that I get weirded up yeah the one
on the right guys
wait you know what's crazy so that's her
it it's probably not that hard to find
someone you think looks cool there's so
many people like her but that girl on
the right don't look like her though
they don't look good to me I mean you
stab the face enough but they look
related you go to Glendale you find a
bunch of people
I'm laughing because it's Americana
versus Galleria oh that's true that you
you're right though the one on left is
Galleria they're both on brand damn that
girl just wanted like a like a makeup
thing man why didn't you go to [__]
Bloomingdale's and [__] or Macy's like
when you're at the mall there's the
whole makeup ladies they do the free
makeup for you so okay so let's start
poking holes and why this was a dumb
idea other than the fact that the DNA
testing right like were they not gonna
think that I don't know the other chick
the victim had like friends or family
members that would corroborate the fact
that she was missing
they were blinded by well she was
missing but then they found her in her
own car dead see no not her own car in
the other girl's car yeah the other
girls I had an 80d moment why did she
want to do this again run off with her
boyfriend they were blinded by love
that's the whole that's the reason but
why why did why did they why can't they
just run away why did they had to kill
someone don't approve I'm glad Joe
called himself out before you asked the
question there's so many stupid things
about the plan one of them being that
even without DNA the fact that if you
take somebody away from like their
routine and you kill them then they will
immediately be noticed that they're
missing right yeah and then all you have
to do is look at recent found bodies and
connect it and go hey you haven't been
seen and we found this so could that be
her like you have to keep someone's
routine the same way well beyond when
you killed
to buy her way out of this [__] mess
she should have just opened the only
fans bam millionaire overnight you get a
new life you get a new life yeah you get
to buy a new life you don't like where
the hell you're living go live somewhere
else now go live in Turkey her parents
don't approve of some [__] I'm surprised
she just didn't kill her parents for not
approving if she's willing to kill it
not because she's gonna get caught
so stupid yeah what yeah what why would
you what are what are Pros to faking
your own death
um I mean if it's not like Chris Souza's
Dad I know if remember Crystal's dad he
faked his own death so yeah to get away
which is assassinated find his murder
that's one thing also to escape
persecution for something you're guilty
of oh or to uh what did she just move to
a [__] non-extradition country then
well you might have to maybe have to
fake your death to get out what if
you're a mafia member in the 1920s and
then you wanna like fake her death and
move to Utah or something dude faking
your death has been so easy but I know
there's no security cameras we're also
way smarter so it is easier to go and
back in time but using 1920s IQ is
probably still hard as [__] yeah because
it's all relative it's true yeah they
weren't as smart yeah replacing a
wealthy guy
right you take him out you slide right
in everyone thinks you're him yeah like
The Count of Monte Cristos and [__] like
that ooh the count of money Chris that's
the true story The True Story by the way
because I remember looking at old
documents I'm like dude anybody can
force this [__] probably back then they
couldn't but not a lot of people know
how to raid read and write back they
didn't have they didn't have Photoshop
back but dude
it doesn't matter there's a chair over
there professional show what is your
opinion what is your opinion on
murdering someone that looks just like
you
do we look like please don't
that's a professional state ment please
don't
oh it's good well I'm gonna be do they
have the same personality as me yeah
they're late like you
they're very perennially late okay then
then um
then uh then to kill them
[Music]
I like the self-loathing what do you
think about German Iraqi girls with big
titties
how big are the titties I like the girl
she killed more
it was hotter really you like Americana
girl not a girl I'm not into Galleria
girl but aren't they both owned by the
same person
yeah
is it Krikorian
who do you like better I like the girl
on the right are they the same but no
they're not they're right ones one of
them's very dead I go right because very
what very dead oh uh it says victim in
the corner
I didn't see I was focusing on her face
man oh yeah it does huh at least Oh I
thought it says supreme Supreme I'm
proud of myself because I thought the
victim was hotter I I think yeah the
victim is hard I actually didn't see
that before I agree with that I didn't
see it either it is limited edition I'm
good about that you want to save her
yeah too late so what happened here hey
that means we're not gay right
she wanted to fake her own death so she
killed someone that looks like her
implanted that's not how gay Works what
and wanted to run away with her
boyfriend isn't that crazy that's very
smart though oh you think it's smart she
was caught immediately by the way that's
not cool
how is that smart give us a new
perspective because we know none of us
not a smart time
because you killed because if I don't
want to die you know what I mean and
then I want to other people to think
that I died they're not gonna kill
something like me but she doesn't need
people to think she's dead yeah she
could have just ran away she's just
trying to so would you would you kill
Jason Chen the singer
I would and you don't even have to be
there
just unrelated
I don't even know who Jason Cheney was
and I already want to [__] kill Jason
Chen so it's like
I would kill I would kill Jason Derulo
why why would you like him that just
sounds like a death he's a jealous
it's not racial because he's black
probably I'm
just Virgil because he's blessed
oh no oh God I got it just Spike his
whole set
[Music]
oh